mount elgon in eastern uganda a volcano
that's been extinct for many centuries
fertile soil and sufficient water make
it a unique ecosystem in 1993 the
mountain was declared in nature reserve
enterta seeker one of the park rangers
tells us more than 30,000 people had to
be resettled back then because if they
are to stay in the pack then they do the
activities and they will end up spoiling
the ecosystem and the streams of water
which are coming from the mountains the
mountain region is a habitat for rare
plant species one of them even owes its
name to the mountain lobelia Aragorn
ensis if they are destroyed then the
whole world will miss the only fold up
here day mountain many animals used to
live up here now there are only just a
few monkey species most of the large
animals were killed or driven away by
humans for example the elephants when
they were hunted these are animals with
a very high memory in that when one of
them is killed we will never forget
where the friend died flow and they will
never cross there Rangers patrol the
National Park daily sometimes they come
across people setting fires illegally
which often leads to larger wildfires
and they were such person is arrested
then you take that person in prison it's
just given a one-day woo in prison then
the second day you see the same password
moving around you but the people in the
valley have their own struggles because
of the resettlement their field suddenly
had to provide for more people soon the
soil was exhausted for four years
there's been help from the United
Nations Development Programme Henry
Mukasa teaches people how they can grow
more
crop rotation for instance this is where
the project comes in and undp says that
look we can still be able to use the
same piece of land because there is not
going to be added land we can still be
able to use the same piece of land but a
little bit more sustainably so that we
improve its productivity the project
ends at the end of 2015 after that the
people around Mount Elgon will have to
cope on their own